At this software company,
pay negotiations are conducted
a little differently.
Here it's your colleague
that sets your salary.
Because we trust them,
we should have transparency
that will be paid back
by more trust from the people
in the team, the company.
And that will create a
positive feedback loop
that will benefit everyone.
Buenos Aires based 10Pines,
has an open book management style
that allows employees to have
a say in all major decisions,
including who they hire
and how much they're paid.
In the final interview
of the hiring process,
the candidate meets the entire
company, around 90 people,
who in turn decide if they're a good fit
and then their starting salary.
It's important that if
this person, new hire,
enters the company,
then everyone will know the salary
and will accept and will acknowledge
that it looks at least,
with a small information that
we have from that person,
it looks fair at that time.
Three times a year
the company has a rates meeting
in which employees can pitch and present
why they deserve a raise
before their teammates take a vote.
We live in a market that
it's competing all the time
for the talent.
And of course, one of the
ways that it compete is
by paying and raising
salaries all the time.
So it's an important aspect
that people needs to know
if they are being paid
a fair salary or not.
10Pines calls this sociocracy.
And although it may sound unique,
its practices are
grounded in a larger trend
known as radical transparency.
Right now we're really fertile ground
for this kind of idea to sprout up.
And I think we're going to see
many, many, many things kind of popping up
all over the world.
Many, many experiments over
the next couple of years
in this approach.
And so, as companies and employees
start to look towards a
post pandemic workplace,
could honesty really be the best policy?
Radical transparency is a
concept that broadly applied
just means being super transparent
about details that a
company or an organization
might otherwise choose to
keep secret or keep hidden
or limited to a certain
number of executives
or leaders at a company.
Netflix is one of the companies
best known for its culture
of radical transparency
that it says promotes accountability.
Netflix, the company, takes
radical transparency very far
and they go so far as to have, you know,
public discussions or public
emails sent out to, you know,
sometimes hundreds of employees
discussing why someone was fired.
Sometimes the discussions about
why someone is getting fired
happen right in front of them,
so that they have a chance
to share all the ways
that they made mistakes
that led to them no longer
working at the company.
But they also have policies
that people might see as pretty welcome.
So for example,
they allow their employees to
sort of, at their discretion,
make use of their expense accounts.
So that means no one's really
tracking their vacation days
or their expense spending
or things that are you know,
useful to this person
getting their job done.
And the idea is that it's freedom
and sort of freedom and responsibility
that is given to these employees
so that they have a chance to
do their job the best they can
without being micromanaged.
But you only have to look at Netflix
on Glassdoor to see that this
approach isn't for everyone.
Anytime you have a company culture
that's sort of extreme,
you have the chance to attract people
for whom it's really a good fit.
And you're also going to
turn off a lot of people
who just feel that this isn't for them.
And it may explain why
this isn't a more widely adopted thing
because it's difficult
and it requires someone at
the top, really committed,
to working through the
uncomfortable parts of it
in order to make it the company culture.
For Netflix,
that person at the top is Reed Hastings.
He believes the company's success
stems from its high performance culture.
In the traditional industrial
paradigm, you know,
you have to do something
wrong to get let go.
You can think of a job as
sort of a property right.
You know, until you lose it
by abusing your position.
But if you think about
professional sports, you know,
if that team is going
to win a championship,
it has to have a mix of the right players
that work well together,
that are the absolute best in the world.
And so we try to model ourselves
like a professional sports team.
So highly paid,
but you got to earn your
position every year.
And it's about performance.
And you know, that's
not right for everybody.
Some people care mostly
about job security.
Other people care mostly
about excellent colleagues
and you know, playing great team ball
to achieving something
important for the consumers.
And the Netflix numbers
seem to show that radical
transparency is working,
while it fires people at a higher rate
than the average US company.
People actually choose to
leave at a much lower rate.
But you also don't hear
about the companies
for which this didn't work so well, right.
Or the companies that might
have gotten to midsize
and then things sort of fizzled out.
Or you know, we look at
Netflix and Bridgewater
and we see these success stories,
but we're also not hearing
necessarily the stories
where it was hard to keep
a company culture going
as it grew much bigger
or it was hard to keep it going
as the company expanded very quickly.
But beyond company success,
how does this high accountability system
impact the average employee?
So from a neuroscience perspective,
if we think about what the
brain is innately craving,
like the brain's own goals,
one of them is a sense of certainty.
Like the ability to predict
what's going to happen the next second.
When you feel, you know, uncertain,
it activates quite a strong
threat response in the brain,
which takes your attention away from
what you're trying to focus on.
When certainty goes up,
you activate a reward network in the brain
and your field of view literally opens up
your perspective and how much
you can think about opens up
and your ability to be creative.
So one of the things with
radical transparency is
people have a lot more certainty
about what's expected of them,
about what great performance
looks like in any domain,
about what other people are doing,
how that compares to what they're doing.
So it really increases
your access to information.
So you can feel a lot more certain
about everything that's
going on in your world.
And this drive for certainty
is such a fundamental part of the brain.
It's literally one of the
brain's intrinsic goals.
And it's not just
an increased sense of certainty
that could help us do our jobs.
When you give people
access to information about
who's paid what and how
and what they're doing and
how the whole business works
and the whole infrastructure,
people feel a much
greater sense of control.
They feel like they can make decisions.
They feel like they are
able to to take actions
and as a result,
improve their career or their performance.
While a radical transparency model
may check out on a biological level.
It definitely isn't a one
size fits all solution.
As humans we have incredible
neural diversity, right?
There are people who thrive
under incredible pressure.
And in fact, they're really bored
unless there's enormous change
and uncertainty going on.
And there are people who will fall apart
if the subway schedule changes.
I will say that radical
transparency as a concept,
will suit a number of
kinds of organizations
or maybe even functions.
It doesn't mean necessarily
it will suit every person
or even necessarily every organization.
It's interesting because
I think there are certain companies
that have been pushing really
hard for radical transparency
for a long time, for a decade plus.
And it hasn't had quite
this moment of, you know,
a moment in time in which
it became very popular.
I think that's because
it's probably quite hard
to adjust to
and so you see companies
who really define themselves
as a company culture,
try to differentiate
themselves from other companies
by emphasizing radical transparency.
But those companies in my view,
remain pretty few and far between.
In addition to the potential legal issues
surrounding employee performance
and termination transparency,
a major hurdle for many companies
is making salaries public.
Yep. It's 2021.
And women are still
being paid less than men
for doing the same jobs.
One step in the direction of
amending this reality
is to have pay transparency.
In the case of pay transparency,
there's this pretty strong argument that
actually hiding pay between your employees
can hold people back.
It lets certain employees get paid more
and certain employees go
underpaid for a long time
without knowing.
And so there's, I think,
a pretty strong argument to be made that,
you know, that pay
transparency's more fair.
A 2021 Washington University study
found that pay secrecy
directly contributes
to the continued pay inequality
between men and women doing the same role.
I wouldn't be surprised
if certain of the more palatable
or easy to digest changes
that come with radical transparency,
say maybe like pay transparency.
I think that's something
that more companies
could get on board with adopting.
It's less of a culture shock than
changing the way that you
do all sorts of feedback
or firings or meetings or
sensitive things like that.
And if that becomes more and more common,
then you'll see companies who
want to distinguish themselves
thinking about, well, what's next?
Like what is something else
that we can be changing
about how we run our business,
that's going to make
us better and different
from our competitors?
A year of remote working
has challenged us to rethink
many of our traditional work models.
And while radical transparency,
in its most extreme form,
may not become the norm,
some of it's central
practices like flexibility,
employee autonomy and openness,
maybe on the way.
What the pandemic, in
the last year, has done
is it's kind of given a lot of people
a lot more clarity about
what matters to them
and a lot more willingness to speak up
and also vote with their feet.
And I think what we're
going to see as a result
is what might've taken kind of
five to ten years to happen,
I think it's going to
happen in one to two,
in terms of organizational culture.
I don't necessarily predict a revolution,
but I predict some
revolutionary approaches
are going to start taking
hold in organizations
in the next couple of years.
We're seeing that in a
really short amount of time,
things changed so dramatically.
And for some organizations, for example,
it was impossible to think like
people working from their home all day.
And from one day to the other,
we're forced to move to that situation.
And it just so that people keep working
and things keep moving
and it's possible to do such things.